hello freak like who was it was
it who one of the guests I had in the
past Hal sparks I think was how sparks
that went over to Dubai and he he it did
a bit and he was told by one of the
people in the audience he was going to
be arrested because he referred to one
of the royal family by the wrong name
called him sir instead of your highness
and so they were gonna arrest him Wow
but then some other member of the royal
family stepped in and stopped it because
they said no he was respectful and he
just didn't understand the tradition
protocol yeah but they were ready to
lock him up in a cage coz he
used the wrong term not even in a
disrespectful manner right yeah just
just called him Sir you know whoa yeah
like that's not the place that I'm going
I'm just I'm not interested in any place
look man there's a real problem with
Canada right now you know I know you
know what happened in Vancouver where a
comic was heckled by these lesbians yes
and he all over them and then they
sued him and won yeah because he had
done something to violate their human
rights because they were heckling not
just him but people before him they were
disrupting a live performance so do you
think that this trend of famous comics
refusing to perform at universities is
only going to continue to increase or
again have we reached the maximum and
now there's gonna be blowback because I
know Jerry Seinfeld doesn't do it Chris
Rock doesn't do it right I haven't done
it since 2003 maybe was the last time I
did a show yeah I don't think they have
enough life experience you know I like
to talk to people that have lived when I
when I talk to people I want to talk to
someone who has had affairs love affairs
and has had jobs and been fired has had
education and as I want someone with
life experience not there's anything
wrong with being 18 or whatever 19 but I
want someone who's got some living under
their belt so they know what the
I'm talking about I don't wanna have to
explain everything I don't I mean I did
a concert once
concert I did a show once at a
university and I was talking about
something sexual and I saw this
bewildered looks in the audience I know
how many you people are virgins I go
don't don't even raise your hand because
I don't criminate you I could just blink
real fast and they started laughing but
it would got real uncomfortable I go
would you again I go I'm not gonna even
look at you I go I'm gonna look at the
sky would you say that I would be out of
line if I said ten percent of you were
virgins and the place went there one no
no that's probably about right people
like yelling I'm like that's crazy
ten percent of you are virgins that's
like if there's 200 people that twenty
of you are virgins really that's
a lot of people right it's probably more
than that they're probably being modest
or not being honest about it I just it's
not nothing wrong with being college
obviously but as far as like where I
want to perform I don't have a lot of
you know if I have a day there's 24
hours in that day I don't have a lot of
hours to perform at night if I'm
performing at night I get a couple hours
you know I'd like I like doing actual
comedy I like doing what I do and then
one of the things about comedy is it's
it's different than any other art form
in that like say if you go to see music
like you know what you're gonna go see
you don't usually just say oh live music
like well let's hope that it's something
I'm interested in you know we're gonna
see jay-z followed by Johnny Cash
followed by Loretta Lynn no it's not
gonna be that way you're gonna go to a
rock-and-roll club you go to the Viper
Room most likely gonna hear some
rock-and-roll you go to a
country-western bar you can see that I
think with stand-up comedy people get
upset if you're not doing like what
appeals to them and their sensibilities
so I like to go to nightclubs
that's what I like I don't even do
corporate gigs I get a lot of offers who
do these corporate gigs and they'll
they'll pay you a lot of money cuz
they'll be to tame the audience they
won't know it's just like it's not a
it's not a real comedy show it's like
you guys are pay it's like you're GAD
sad paying 50 grand to have these guys
sing in your backyard some weird ego
thing right I saw my friend Dana White
who was he's the head of the UFC he had
a birthday party years back and Stone
Temple Pilots played before that dude
died of an overdose plant and and
pay attention it was weird Stone Temple
Pilots mean they kind of got everybody
to pay attention got everybody to move
towards the stage but people a didn't
know to expect Stone Temple Pilots it
was a big surprise and when I even
introduced them when I introduced Stone
Temple Pilots people didn't even think
that it was really gonna be Stone Temple
Pilots like I said happy birthday to
Dana thanked him for everything and then
I said and I'm gonna you know blow your
mind right now
ladies and gentlemen Stone Temple Pilots
and they came out and it was really
stoned Temple Pilots and they they went
hard they did their it was really really
impressive stuff because they did their
full-on concert like a hundred percent
all-out it was intense
it was really amazing but it wasn't a
lot of people pay attention and why was
while I was sitting there watching I was
like you know what yeah never again I'm
never doing
I mean I had already decided I wasn't
gonna do it I wasn't going to just do
that anyway
[Applause]
[Music]